hello there
myth chasers it's time once again to
test out your weird and wonderful myths
and theories in the ever-changing world
of fortnite battle royale
if you have a myth that needs busting
throw it in the comments below and the
best ones will be chosen in the next
episode so
upvote your favorites to make them
easier for me to spot
please think about using code adamaru to
keep this series going and if you aren't
already
now is a good time to subscribe it's
free after all anyway sit your butt down
for 10 minutes
let's chase some myths
[Music]
our first myth of the day is from
crazycut who asks
with doom's arcane gauntlets how many
people can you chain the damage with i
love this myth as you know by now one of
doom's attacks sends a green bolt of
energy through a player
and if anyone is close enough the energy
will leap over to them
and smash them with the same damage the
question is
if we get people together how many
people will that continually chain
through
so i put out a call on my discord and we
all met around this grumpy bush
without realizing we made a doctor
disrespect tim the tatman face
once the group grabbed the weapons the
question was simple if i shot one player
in this circle
would the blast travel through every
other person
well here we go
okay so that was very random it doesn't
look like distance matters at
all so let's try it again
nope right away we can bust this myth
that everyone will take damage
they simply don't so i lined everyone up
in a straight line this time to make it
easier to understand what happens to the
lightning
i asked them to stand up if they were
hit by the blast
here we go
[Music]
so as you can see the blast will only
hit seven people
maximum before the charge empties we
tried this multiple
times to test this theory including
using pretty humongous gaps between
players and the results were conclusive
doom's arcane gauntlets can chain
together seven strikes
between players well this is like a real
science class
next myth please
remember when the cars update dropped
and i thought we'd have myths to chase
for months
well we didn't have that many actually
but one myth took
my eye check this out can you recreate
the car update trailer and see
if the helicopter really does explode
like that
i like this myth so i'm sure you've seen
the trailer in which all the vehicles in
the game
go on this epic road race of carnage
ending like
this a huge ball of fire engulfs
everyone
when a land vehicle hits a flying
vehicle
so our task is to use the same setup on
the same bridge
and recreate that moment and see if a
direct hit from a 4x4 would result
in explosion like that so we set off
this time with a much smaller group of
people from the discord because everyone
was asleep
who knew that was a thing we had a
director this time keeping things on
track
and this here is our first effort
okay hitting a helicopter from a ramp on
a mountaintop
is way more difficult than we first
expected or maybe we're just complete
losers
both probably we tried and tried
and tried and somehow we finally got
there here is how it went down i'll cut
in the shot at the perfect time in the
trailer
[Music]
so that was another epic failure the
integrity of a helicopter is
far higher than a land vehicle and
simply throws the truck to the side
for this to work we needed to get the
chopper down to a single hit
which we did and here is our final
attempt at recreating
the explosion
so technically it is possible to
recreate the opening joyride trailer
but there's a little more to unpack here
firstly
i decided to hide in a bush nearby to
see if the explosion was as wide as i
thought
and would wipe me out too and yeah holy
heck it did
the blast eliminated everyone everyone
except
the choppers pilot so what have we
learned here
the chopper is mightier than the motor
car and fortnite trailers
are not always completely made in-game
let's have another myth panda panda
panda asks
can mystique lift thor's hammer out of
the crater
wow this is big brain material here so
can mystique
lift thor's hammer for this one i needed
to grind to level 86 in the battle pass
to unlock mystique and her abilities and
in real life i just spent real money
because i'm a sellout and i thought if i
didn't do this quick
enough someone else would do this in the
myth-chasing community
anyway so i quickly completed the
challenges to get mystique's new ability
and all the while i left thor's
challenges completely alone
then a friend and i jumped into a game i
was mystique he was thor
he gave his life to try this myth out i
used mystique's intrinsic ability to
become thor
and the moment came is mystique able to
lift
thor's hammer
um well no this was complete failure
which led to me being eliminated
nothing happened at all but that's not
the end of this story
i loaded up the replay file like i do
with all these videos
and check out what happened
in the replay mystique dressed as thor
did indeed lift thor's hammer for a
moment
before the hammer switched back to be my
fork knives again
so here's my issue is this a successful
myth
or a busted one in game nothing happened
but in the replay file
mystique lifted thor's hammer was it a
glitch
hell yes it was as mjolno was still on
the ground as well as in thor's hand
i mean mystique's hand unless they can
duplicate hammers
this myth is busted but hey that glitch
was totally worth spending crazy amounts
of money on
let's keep tracking next myth please
do the stark bots have glider redeploy
hmm i never thought about that good
question
the stark tech bots can be found around
the map guarding the quinjets
will they pop a shoot when forced into
the air the problem we have
is that the launch pads have been
vaulted from the game so we need to
think deeper here
here's the plan we hack the bots and
then make them followers
all the way to steamy stacks to answer a
double myth
what happens when a stark bot reaches
steamy stacks and if they do fly
will they pop a parachute let's do this
luckily there is a spot near steamy
stacks which was super easy to get to
the difficulty though was actually
getting the bots to go into steamy
stacks they constantly broke our builds
in the end we used fishing rods and
here's what happens
the bots fly in steamy stacks but the
surprise here is that they do not
ever open a shoot there is no gliderity
plug on these things
they sort of slow down as if they have a
glider but nothing is there
pretty cool indeed i also found out
today that we can build over steamy
stacks
and edit all tiles regardless of if
they're in contact with
anything at all i mean it's totally
broken up here but i had a lot of fun
i know you think this is pointless and
you're right but pointless
is what we do around here oh and here's
another myth whilst we're on stark bots
[Music]
super says myth can stark's robots use
rifts
so once again we hacked the bots and led
them to the rifts
and although they had trouble doing what
they were asked they finally obliged and
have a look at this
the bot does indeed use the rift and now
we know there is no glider redeploy are
they just going to go splat
well no they actually slowly descend
landing perfectly before going back
into their random shooty bang bang mode
happy days okay let's fit in one last
one and it's from my own son
[Music]
zander asks what is in the locked room
on the helicopter base
so let me translate on the helicarrier
is a super secret vault hiding in plain
sight
the thing is it's completely locked and
we are unable to find the key and
unlock it what on earth could be inside
well this is an easy one to solve as we
have a free camera and can check
in replay mode are you ready for this
mind-blowing item inside
it turns out all your friends are
waiting inside
look all none of them sorry i don't know
why i made this about you
yep there is absolutely nothing in this
room at all
i'll be sure to keep an eye on it
because having this mechanic in the
lobby could be something in the future
so i'll keep an eye on it and let you
know what's going on
[Music]
so there we have it a load more fortnite
myths chased and busted
if you've stayed this long here's a
digital high five for you
thanks for sticking around on screen now
are more absolute legends
who are kind enough to rock my code
adamara in the store then send me a dm
over on twitter
my intention is to reply to everyone
thanks for supporting me i really
appreciate it
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign